poutine qui voient d'un mauvais oeil
l'entrée probable des pays baltes et de
l'ukraine dans l'otan c'est ce qu'il a
confié dans un entretien exclusif à
christian malard et victor arish à
l'occasion du 60e anniversaire de la
capitulation nazie le président russe a
accepté de dresser un état des lieux de
la russie d'aujourd'hui il répond
notamment aux accusations
d'autoritarisme dont il fait l'objet
aujourd'hui lorsque l'état essaye d'être
fort et plus efficace il y as chez nous
et chez vous des gens qui ne l'admettent
pas aux chaînes et les poursuites que
nous avons lancée contre certaines
sociétés et retiennent votre attention
vous faites leur avocat alors qu'avec
certains autres groupes elles ont essayé
de s'emparer des propriétés de l'état
vous savez il ne s'agit pas de gens
pauvres ce sont des gens très riches qui
en cinq ans ont gagné chacun 6 à 7
milliards de dollars ils n'ont pas
besoin d'être défendue je suis convaincu
que la démocratie n'est pas le doute
permis et l'anarchie je suis persuadé
que l'économie de marché ne doit pas
s'accompagner de l'appauvrissement de
millions de gens des chais de la
concentration de milliards entre les
mains de quelques personnes ce sont là
des procès des criminels je suis
déterminé à poursuivre l'économie de
marché à développer le multipartisme et
renforcer l'indépendance des médias par
le biais de leur autonomie financière
mardi prochain vous allez mettre au
point avec l'union européenne un plan
d'action commun auriez vous préféré en
être membre à part entière
il faut que les deux côtés soit prêt à
coopérer un rythme qui soit acceptable
par les deux parties il est absolument
hors de question pour nous russe que
l'europe soit à nouveau divisée et je
n'exclus pas qu'un certain moment notre
coopération de par sa densité ressemble
à une adhésion à l'union européenne le
président est ce qu une europe qui
pourrait être fragilisé par un non
français à la constitution européenne
poserait problème à vos intérêts
18 ce n'est pas notre affaire
mais laissez moi vous dire que nous
avons certains problèmes dans nos
relations avec l'union européenne
notre problème majeur c'est que nous
n'avons pas d'interlocuteur le président
change tous les six mois ses
démocratique mais en terme de gestion ce
n'est pas très efficace si l'europe peut
être un centre fort de la politique
mondiale elle doit résoudre ses
problèmes économiques et sociaux elle
doit être homogène et plus efficace
depuis la fin de la guerre froide quel
jugement portez vous aujourd'hui sur
l'otan qui essayent d'étendre son
influence à vos voisins à vos
partenaires comme l'ukraine et la
géorgie
le fait que l'otan exerce une grande
influence sur l'ukraine et la géorgie ne
nous as dispose pas en revanche tout
élargissement de l'otan n'améliorerait
pas la sécurité du monde je ne vois pas
en quoi l'élargissement à nos voisins
baltes par exemple peut améliorer la
sécurité du monde cela dit si d'autres
républiques de l'ex urss adhère à l'otan
nous respecterons leur choix on à fait
leur droit souverain en matière de
défense mais certains problèmes
pourraient surgir dans le cadre de notre
coopération militaire avec l'ukraine qui
est énorme
cette coopération est un tel niveau que
s'il devait y avoir une présence
militaire de l'otan en ukraine jeunes y
maintiendrait plus nos technologies de
pointe et nos armements sensible
l'ukraine pourrait alors avoir des
problèmes je le dis franchement
enfin au moment où nous allons
commémorer le 60e anniversaire de la
victoire je veux dire que c'est une
chance de pouvoir tourner définitivement
cette page douloureuse de l'histoire de
l'europe elle est à la base de la
concorde de la réconciliation cela nous
permettra d'élaborer des principes
clairs et compréhensibles qui vont nous
guider dans les années à venir
[Musique]